you
a noiseless patient spider I marked were
on a little promontory it stood isolated
mark'd how to explore the vacant vast
surrounding it launched forth filament
filament filament out of itself ever
unreeling them ever tirelessly speeding
them and you oh my soul where you stand
surrounded detached in measureless
oceans of space ceaselessly musing
venturing throwing seeking the spheres
to connect them to the bridge you will
need be form'd
to the ductile anchor hole to the
gossamer thread you fling catch
somewhere o my soul
a noiseless patient spider I marked
where on a little promontory it stood
isolated mark'd how to explore the
vacant vast surrounding it launched
forth filament filament filament out of
itself ever unreeling them ever
tirelessly speeding them and you oh my
soul where you stand
surrounded detached in measureless
oceans of space ceaselessly musing
venturing throwing seeking the spheres
to connect them till the bridge you will
need be form'd till the ductile anchor
hold till the gossamer thread you fling
catch somewhere o my soul
a noiseless patient spider I marked
where on a little promontory it stood
isolated mark'd how to explore the
vacant vast surrounding it launched
forth filament filament filament out of
itself ever unreeling them ever
tirelessly speeding them and you oh my
soul where you stand
surrounded detached in measureless
oceans of space ceaselessly musing
venturing throwing seeking the spheres
to connect them till the bridge you will
need be form'd
till the ductile anchor hold till the
gossamer thread you fling catch
somewhere o my soul
you
you